[Applaudissements]
collègue madame la Première ministre
samedi à Lyon une cinquantaine de
membres de l'extrême droite néonazie ont
attaqué une conférence du collectif
Palestine 69 après avoir déambulé plus
d'une heure dans les rues avec des
barres de fer je voudrais ici avoir une
pensée pour les victime de cette attaque
d'une grande lâcheté une des personnes
présentes dira au service de police
avoir reçu des coups de barre de fer
elle en ressortira avec 15 jours d'ITT
au total se blessés dans la même soir qu
étudiants en école d'ingénieur ont été
ciblés depuis le local identitaire la
traboule et une jeune fille a été
poursuivie et tabassée par le
groupuscule les remparts 3 jours d'ITT
dès lors nous avons vu sur des boucles
télégram publ les protagonistes de ces
raides revendiquer leurs actes je
voudrais dire ici solennellement notre
colère madame la Première ministre
pendant que vous prépariez la marche
avec Madame Le Pen des militants
d'extrême droite s'organisai pour cibler
des personnes âgées et des jeunes 30
novembre 2022 6 décembre 2022 9 mai 2023
TR courriers des quatre députés nupes du
rô à propos des d'agressions
équivalentes restez tous sans réponse
alors comment 50 militants en cagoulé et
armé ont pu déambuler près d'une heure
dans les rues sans être
appréhendés ce sont au moins six
agressions en 3 ans qui ont été rendu
public on ne parle pas des autres
qu'attendez-vous pour engager des
dissolutions des groupuscules les
remparts et lions populair prenez-vous
l'engagement de fermer définitivement
les locaux identitaire que sont la
traboule et la gaugé et de dissoudre
leur association de gestion agissez
madame la Première ministre nous
n'acceptons pas que nos concitoyens
soient attaqués sur la base de leur
couleur de peau du parler de leurs
parents ou de leurs idées de leurs
croyances ou de leurs convictions merci
beaucoup
coup la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
verrand porte-parole du gouvernement et
ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Amar nous condamnons
avec la plus grande fermeté les
exactions commises par ce groupuscule
d'ultr droite à Lyon le ministre de
l'Intérieur a eu l'occasion de le dire
la justice de notre pays et Cisy au
moins une arrestation a été faite une
enquête va avoir lieu qui permettra
d'avoir des réponses et s'il y a lieu de
dissourre une association organisée à
Lyon comme ça a été le cas d'ailleurs
avec le bastion social qui a été dissour
en 2019 notre main ne tremblera pas nous
luttons monsieur le député contre la
violence nous luttons contre la violence
de l'ultra droite nous nous luttons
aussi contre la violence de l'ultra
gauche quand elle existe monsieur le
député dans votre question qui aurait
presque pu entraîner un consensus vous
vous êtes permis de pointer du doigt la
manifestation en corrélant les acte
commis par cette action cette groupe
d'ultr droite à la manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme en disant pendant que
vous défilz à côté de Mar madame Marine
Le Pen monsieur le député je vais vous
dire le fond de ma pensée vous luttez
contre l'extrême droite alors arrêtez de
la faire monter vous faites peur aux
Français vous faites peur aux
Français dimanche à la manifestation à
laquelle vous avez refusé de participer
contre l'antisémitisme des habitants de
Grenoble sont venus me voir en disant
vous comprenez Monsieur Mélenchon nous
fait tellement peur qu'on hésite à voter
Madame Le Pen ayez conscience des mots
de vos députés ayez conscience des actes
de Madame auonau des actes de Monsieur
leoman ayez conscience des atrocités
raconté par monsieur guireot qui a
inventé le révisionnisme avant l'heure
ayez conscience que votre chef bien-aimé
Monsieur Mélenchon fait beaucoup de mal
à notre pays à la cohésion nationale et
qu'il fait monter constamment l'extrême
droite après vous pourrez nous donner le
son d'abord regardez-vous dans une
glace je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre